greetings everyone I'm Jeff from the
overwatch team we're here with the
developer update about overwatch year of
the rooster in particular we're really
excited to talk about the new brawl that
we added which we named capture the
rooster so as you guys know we have a
tendency to name things just a little
bit differently what you're used to
obviously capture the rooster is our
version of capture the flag and capture
the flag is a really interesting topic
for us to discuss because it's something
we've mentioned in the past as having
had a lot of trouble with when it comes
to tuning and balancing around overwatch
hero so to give you guys a little bit of
history with capture the flag we started
working on it before the game was even
announced we would do various prototypes
of different game modes and see if we
can make it work what we generally have
found with over watch over the years is
that the game works best when we have a
single objective game mode type and if
you think about control assault our
hybrids are payloads they all have one
objective you're either attacking or
defending or you need to take control of
the point or you already have that point
and you need to defend it and capture
the flag is very unique in the sense for
overwatch that there are two objectives
going on at once there's your flag the
enemy flag and you're having to decide
how many resources you dedicate to
getting their flag or to defending your
flag and both flags are on play at the
same time so we really wrestle with
capture the flag over the years for a
number of reasons the primary one is
that over watch heroes are designed
intentionally with really powerful
feeling mobility ability so obvious
examples are Ganges dash tracers blink
you've got Winston's leap Deva can fly
through the air with her boost so
there's a lot of great mobility going on
it's challenging with capture the flag
which is a very mobile game mode type
you're trying to get this thing in an
enemy base and bring it back to your own
with these types of abilities in place
so over the years as we were iterating
and testing various versions of capture
the flag we actually gave up on the mode
for a while because we felt like what we
didn't want to do was add a bunch of
rules that no longer made over watch
heroes feel like over watch heroes I'll
give you some examples of this in one of
our earliest versions that we had there
was no pickup time on the flag and we
had a character like tracer well what
our tracers would do when we were play
testing these early prototypes is they
would triple blink to the flag obviously
they would pick it up since there was no
capture time and then just hit recall
and be you know 30 meters back to where
they were literally untouchable to get
the flag and defenders of the flag
didn't even know what had happened you
know oh my god our flag is gone where
did it go well tracer is you know
already capping it so as we got into
preparing for capture the rooster and
the overwatch Lunar New Year event we
started thinking to ourselves you know
the players keep asking us for capture
the flag and there's a lot of great
suggestions in the community how to make
it work we've tried it before but should
we try it again and this time we took a
different philosophy to it so early on
when we started iteration for capture
the rooster we said well we can we can
do all these things to our heroes to try
to make it feel a lot more balanced so
we had a version up and running where we
picked the abilities that we picked were
the mobility and immunity abilities so a
great example there is Reapers Wraith
form even zenyatta ultimate
transcendence where he's moving very
fast and he also can't be damaged at all
we picked a bunch of abilities like that
tracers blink recall sombras teleport
beacon and we made it so when you use
those abilities and you were the flag
carrier you just drop the flag on the
spot and for a while we played the mode
this way thinking it would feel more
fair and somehow more about
lens and what it ended up feeling like
to us and we did a lot of play testing
on it was they just didn't feel like
overwatch characters anymore it felt
sort of like a drag almost to be the
flag carrier one of the fantasies there
was getting in grabbing that flag and
really doing the run for your base so
ironically we set up all the abilities
to drop the flag and then we ended up
reverting it all and just saying let's
really go to the spirit of what capture
the flag is to us and we believe is to
our players when we mention it to them
when people think of capture the flag
they think of those great movement
abilities in the really old school games
used to be able to grappling hook all
the way across the map with the flag and
that was one of the fun things we
remember about various CTF modes in fps
so instead of trying to overly balance
an overly tuned overwatch around this
concept of sort of fairness we said why
don't we embrace what our heroes do and
allow them to do that and really the
only couple of rules in play and our
version of capture the flag that might
be different from some of the modes that
you're used to r1 there's a little bit
of a pickup time when you get to the
flag you'll see there's a progress bar
and I'll say capturing when you're there
and it's not terribly long but any
damage interrupts that so that prevents
those really cheesy captures like tracer
triple blinking in and just pressing
recall you know now for tracer to do
that the flag has to be totally
unguarded and she needs at least enough
time to pick up the flag before she can
do that the other rule that we're trying
in capture the rooster is that we don't
require your flag to be at the base when
you capture the enemy's flag so for
those of you who are familiar with world
of warcraft we have a battleground in
there called warsong gulch and this is
something we've worked for years on and
it's one of the the favorite
battlegrounds in world of warcraft and
in world of warcraft we require you
you're too
to have the flag when when you capture
the enemy teams flag but um and it's
cool in world of warcraft because it
creates some gameplay that wasn't as fun
and over watch it was a little bit
problematic in overwatch for us when we
tried it this way where you're the flag
carrier kind of standing around trying
to communicate to your team like hey I'm
not going to be able to hold out that
much longer you guys need to go go find
the flag I can't do it on my own because
the time to kill in the lethality is a
is higher in overwatch it's more
difficult to sort of have those holdout
moments when you still have the flag now
one thing people might be worried about
is and I know we're going to hear this
feedback there are moments where you're
defending the flag your team's flag and
enemies going to come in you're going to
have a cool battle but they're going to
win and grab the flag and there's this
feeling of you know they might use some
really powerful ability Winston sleep is
a great example Winston's going to leap
away with the flagging or say well we
didn't have a chance to get that flag
and we sort of had that feeling as well
and that's why when we were in our
iteration cycle we tried those versions
where it would drop the flag when when
Winston used that leap ability what we
found during that iteration time was
usually there's a teamfight before a
flag cap happens in the first place like
an initial capture where they're
grabbing the flag from your vase and
even with the abilities dropping the
flag if the other team took the flag and
got away they were probably going to cap
it anyway whether or not we let you use
your cool movement abilities or not so
ultimately we really went with more of a
free-form capture the flag where we're
embracing more of what overwatch is
about which is your awesome hero with
your awesome abilities and letting you
use them all the time and we kind of
want to create those crazy moments where
well I didn't realize like you might
think tracer with her blink is the best
flag carrier where do you see Winston
with primal rage what he can do it's
pretty amazing
why we think this is okay is because how
we've positioned capture the rooster
with in overwatch it is in arcade mode
that's part of overwatch year the
rooster it's going to be a three week
event and the mode is going to live in
the arcade we're not adding it to quick
play the quick play rotation we're not
adding it to the competitive rotation we
don't have any plans to we just want
players to see it as a fun mode that
exists in the arcade for the sake of fun
and fun alone and we know like a mode
like mystery heroes that also exists in
the arcade it's not going to be
perfectly tuned and balance for the way
over watch works in competitive or quick
play and we're sort of okay with it
because we want it to be a blow off
steam mode that you go and do in
addition to those other modes so that's
not saying it might never be it won't
ever be a competitive mode maybe you
know some day if we fine-tune and
iterate on it it'll be great and will
think about it that way but we're not
even remotely thinking about that right
now we just want it to be fun we want it
to be for those players who have really
been vocal about asking for capture the
flag we want it to be our way of saying
we're listening to you and that you know
your feedback is important in even game
modes that we sort of had had dismissed
in the past when we hear your repeated
feedback like that we want you to know
that we care about it and we take it
really seriously so we've heard so many
requests for capture the flag we wanted
to bring it to you guys you know maybe
in the future if capture the rooster is
really successful during overwatch year
the rooster will even consider bringing
it back to the arcade in a more fully
fleshed-out version with you know new
maps and that sort of thing but
initially we want to see what your
reaction is and see how much you guys
like it will be really curious to hear
your feedback as you're playing it we
want to hear what's fun we want to hear
what you don't like about it and we'll
we'll look to that feedback to iterate
on it so in the mean
I enjoy the overwatch year the rooster
event enjoy capture the rooster as a
game-mode have lots of fun and be nice
to each other we'll see you guys
[Music]